[Applause]
Less Than 3 days after annulling
elections in gaban and dissolving State
institutions military coup leaders have
voiced a clearer vision for the
country's
future the dissolution of the
institutions of the Republic is
temporary the aim is to reorganize them
to make them more democratic more in
line with International standards in
terms of respect for human rights
fundamental freedoms democracy and the
rule of law but also in the fight
against corruption which has become
common place in our country money
laundering and above all the
preservation of the environment which is
a battle dear to our country earlier
gabon's main opposition candidate Albert
Ando Osa who has claimed victory for
gabon's election spoke he is demanding
an electoral recount and says the coup
is no Revolution but rather a family
affair we need to put things into
context first of all it's not a ketar
it's a palace Revolution olua is alib
bongo cousin the gabes took to the
streets to welcome bongo's departure but
as I said they saw that it wasn't the
Bongos who had left but a bongo who had
replaced another Bongo Ali Bongo coup
leaders took action on Wednesday
detaining president Ali Bongo who has
been in power since 2009 after he was
announced the winner by the Electoral
Authority they accuse Bongo and his
family of high treason stealing billions
in state finances when it comes to
Natural Resources mainly the country's
Rich oil
production opposition members say
regardless of the military's Vision they
must respect the rule of law we are a
democracy and um military has to be
respondent and respect the Constitution
therefore we asking them to end over the
power because the Constitution does not
allow military to lead the
nation the Bond's military leaders look
to usher in a new start for a country
that has been run by a family Dynasty
for over 5 decades but it's unclear if
the people of Gabon will be trusting in
that Vision as the country remains on
edge Imran Alan
alir make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz